We've talked about how we can identify ourselves to a system.
We've talked about how we authenticate ourselves to a system.
We've talked about how we authenticate ourselves to a system
through authentication by knowledge, ownership, or characteristic.
Now, let's talk about how we authorize.
How the system determines what our access will be.
There's three major philosophies for authorization.
The first is known as discretionary access control.
And listen very carefully to this definition.
Discretionary access control means that the owner decides
who's going to get access to the system.
Now, is that a good security practice for the owner decides who should get access?
Absolutely.
Is that commonly what's done?
Unfortunately not.
It's very common that it's not the owner that decides who gets access.
Instead, it's someone an IT or some other system administrator like that.
And they're not the owner of the system.
So the perfect definition of discretionary access means the owner decides.
And there's three types of discretionary access that you need to know about.
There is rule-based, role-based, and attribute-based.
And we'll talk through each of those in more detail in a moment.
The next access control philosophy is non-disgressionary.
So if discretionary means the owner decides what does non-disgressionary mean?
Well, it means someone other than the owner decides.
And as I mentioned, that's very common in the world today in a lot of organizations,
but not a good practice.
The final philosophy is what's known as mandatory access control.
And this is where the system decides.
This is very rarely seen.
And we'll talk about it in a few minutes here, but it's very rare to see mandatory access control.
The two that you'll see the most out in the real world are discretionary and non-disgressionary.
So let's dig into each of these.
Now, relating this back to the reference monitor concepts and security kernels,
what these authorization steps are all about is determining the rules that get fed into our mediation.
And as we talked about in discretionary access, it's the owner that determines these rules.
Now, role-based access is where we have this concept of defining roles
and then assigning users to those roles, which defines what access they get.
And role-based access can be an awesome idea in situations where you've got a ton of users that all share the same role.
Think call centers.
You might have 500 people in a call center.
They all need the same system access.
So you define one role, assign all 500 employees to that one role.
And then if you need to make changes to their access, you only have to update one role.
Makes this very easy.
Now, in my experience, it's often challenging to implement role-based access across the entire organization.
I've been involved in a number of these implementations, and it's not uncommon to end up with more roles than you have employees,
which kind of negates making this whole process more efficient.
The other challenge a lot of organizations have is that many systems don't support role-based access, older legacy systems.
So role-based access create idea.
Not always easy to accomplish.
Rule-based access is where a simple set of rules.
Often, these are known as accles, access control lists.
It's simply a file that says this user has access to this resource or this asset.
So rule-based access is simply a set of rules.
And those rules are going to be unique to each user.
And so if you need to update 10 users access, you'd have to go and update their 10 unique rule sets.
Let's talk about an emerging form of access.
And it's known as attribute-based access.
And to give a bit of context as to why this is really useful and important nowadays,
let's talk about where the industry is trending as it comes to access to systems,
and what type of systems are being created, and where those systems are hosted.
So nowadays, it's very common for most applications to be web-based applications.
And for a lot of those applications to be hosted in the cloud,
which we call software as a service.
Now, if you have an application hosted in the cloud as software as a service,
all of the defense and depth controls that you would have used to have had
when that application was deep within your corporate resources,
or deep within your corporate network, they're gone.
You know, it used to be very common that applications were hosted inside a company's own IT infrastructure.
And there was multiple layers of defense, firewalls, and all sorts of other controls
that would prevent unauthorized users from getting near that secure internal system.
But when we host the system in the cloud, who can access this system?
Potentially anyone on the internet.
And this is where the idea of attribute-based access becomes much more important.
Because the idea here is when we put a system out on the internet,
all those defense and depth controls are now gone.
We don't have those controls in place.
And so the access controls, the controls that we use to control access to the application,
become much, much more important.
And attribute-based access really takes that into account.
Because the idea behind attribute-based access is rather than just looking at a simple user name and password
to grant someone access, and authorize what they're allowed to access,
instead you look at a bunch of attributes such as you could look at the user
and specifically what's their identity, what department do they work in,
what date and time are they logging in from.
You could look at what environment they're logging in from.
Are they using, for instance, a Linux system and everyone in the company is being issued
Macs or Windows computers.
You could look at the operating system they're running.
You could look at even at their geographic location.
A lot of devices nowadays have GPS on board,
so you can see someone's fairly accurate latitude and longitude.
And if they're trying to log in from somewhere sketchy like, say, Canada,
that's going to look instantly suspicious.
You could look at what resources they're wanting to actually access.
Is this top-secret documents?
Is it, you know, is it an entire database or just a file?
And you could even look at what exactly do they want to do?
Do they want to read the file?
Do they want to download the entire thing?
Do they want to modify it?
So you can look at all these different attributes and then,
based on all this, you can make an authorization decision.
And the way that we make these authorization decisions is based on a set of policy,
some logic.
It's basically a set of rules that we program into our authorization engine
so that it then can make a determination as to permit or deny certain actions,
looking at all these different attributes.
So that's the idea behind attribute-based access.
And I'll bet a lot of you have actually seen an example of this recently.
Now, these policies that we use to program our authorization engine,
the language that we use that we write these policy statements in,
is known as XACML, the Extensible Access Control Markup Language.
So just remember that as the language that we use to write the policies in,
attribute-based access.
And you might think attribute-based access is this super rare thing
I've never seen before, but I would bet every single one of you have seen it.
And here's a perfect example.
You've probably logged into a website recently where you had to click a box that said,
I'm not a robot.
How does clicking a box prove that you're not a robot?
Well, what's going on behind the scenes is that Google,
who runs this recapture system, is looking at a whole bunch of different attributes
when you try and click that box.
They're looking at the IP address that you're coming from,
the type of system you're on, how many times you've tried to click on that box
in the last few minutes.
And importantly, they're looking at how you click on that box.
If you were a robot, you'd probably go right to the center of the box,
click dead center, it'd be very mechanical.
If you're a human, you'd probably drunkenly stagger up to the box,
barely get the edge of it.
It would look very different.
And so this whole, I'm not a robot, is looking at all these different attributes
to decide whether you're a robot or not.
Okay, this next little bit, not an exam,
but I think it's a really fun little bit of trivia.
That's quite interesting to know.
So the system before, I'm not a robot checkbox,
used to be this capture system,
where you had to type in this horribly scrambled and mangled text.
Where did that text come from?
For many years, where a lot of that text came from,
was from the Google book scanning project.
Google had a, and they think they stole or doing it,
they had a project where they were trying to scan all the world's old books
so that they could put them online and make them searchable.
Great idea.
The problem was that a lot of these books being very old and kind of rough shape
were very difficult for the OCR, the optical character recognition software
to actually figure out what the letters were.
And so what Google did is they got millions of us all around the world
to translate these books for them.
They would take these mangled bits of text,
they put them in these captures,
and then we would type in what we thought the characters were.
And if enough of us said, oh yeah, that's a B, or that's a J,
then the system would go, okay, yeah, that's the letter,
and that's how the recapture system worked.
So that's where the letters came from.
Where did some of the numbers come from?
Well, for a while there, Google was sourcing the numbers
from their street view project.
Google has been driving cars all around the world,
taking pictures of all the world's streets, and capturing house numbers.
And they wanted to be able to tie a particular picture of a house
to that house number so that when you typed in a address,
they could show you the exact house.
And in some instances, the pictures captured of the house numbers
were tough for the computer system to translate.
And so, what do they do?
They put those numbers into the recapture system.
And millions of us around the world entered what we thought those numbers were,
trained Google's system on how to recognize those numbers and those letters.
So that's kind of where that came from.
Now, one final piece here that's, I think, really cool.
In the new, I'm not a robot system.
It makes a bit of a risk-based decision.
If it's not entirely sure whether you're a robot or not,
it'll actually show you a grid of pictures,
a three-by-three grid of pictures.
And when the system was first put out there,
it was usually pictures of kittens and bunnies.
And they'd ask you to, like, which of the puppies here or which of the kittens?
But now, when you get those grid of pictures, what are most of the pictures?
There's street signs, there's school buses, things like that.
Because what are you training now?
You're training Google's self-driving cars. They're Waymo cars.
So, Google's been very good at figuring out how to get all of us around the world
to work for free to train their machine learning algorithms.
Now, the next type of authorization is mandatory access control.
And we have to spend a minute on this one.
As I want to explain something important,
mandatory access control is very, very rare to see.
Here's why.
In order to have mandatory access control,
every single asset in the organization has to have a classification.
And every single user has to have some sort of security clearance.
Because the system has to decide who's going to get access to what,
based on all this.
And it's very rare for organizations to have classified all of their assets
and to have security clearance and classified all of their users.
So, it's very rare to see mandatory access control outside of US military
and other governmental types of organizations.
So, I'd warn you on the exam.
Mandatory access control is very rarely the right answer.
Because you almost never see it in the real world.
And an important part that you might see on the exam related to mandatory access control
is that it requires labeling.
We have to label our data so that the system can decide who gets access to what.
The final authorization philosophy is non-discretionary.
And non-discretionary means who determines the rules?
Not the owner.
Someone from IT or something like that.
So, there you go.
Those are the major access control philosophies.
Music